toutes les stations de travail ne sont
pas totalement occupés mais déjà
quelques salariés sont sur place comme
leslie elle avait déjà exercé dans un
autre centre d'appels concurrents elle a
répondu à une annonce sur un réseau
social professionnel il y a énormément
d'opportunités d'évolution de carrière
et donc c'est aussi ce que je
recherchais dans un nouveau centre de
relation client de son côté cindy est en
pleine formation auprès d'un client déjà
salarié au sein de la société à gré elle
a profité d'une mobilité pour venir à
chalon j'ai déménagé pour aménager et
c'est après ce qui était intéressant
pour ma part c'est vraiment que le site
soit nouveau et que tout n'est pas
encore à mettre en place
donc on va découvrir plein de nouvelles
choses enfin sévèrement le chargement
l'entreprise n'est pas une inconnue en
bourgogne franche comté
elle a déjà implanté deux sites avec 611
collaborateurs à montceau-les-mines et
133 à gré à terme près de 300 emplois
seront créés sur l'ancien site kodak à
chalon sur saône s'est avéré être le
meilleur bassin d'emploi pour trois
raisons tout d'abord pour la qualité des
profils que l'on peut retrouver ici
second devant pour l'accessibilité
on a des clients à lyon en déclinant
paris on est idéalement ici située à
moins d'une heure trente de lyon et
paris et enfin pour l'infrastructure
près de 2 millions d'euros ont été
investis pour permettre cette nouvelle
implantation
la plateforme travaille déjà avec des
acteurs nationaux comme nespresso ou
boursorama